[Music]
for me without question the start of the
christmas dinner is this a delicious
turkey now once this is in the oven
you're halfway there the secret success
behind a great christmas dinner is
making sure this doesn't turn out dry
and is all in the preparation now we're
going to make an amazing butter
and this
is sort of the start of the the most
important part keeping that bird
incredibly moist soft butter
a touch of salt and pepper
a little touch of olive oil in there
that stops the butter from burning
next add the zest of two lemons
and their juice
this gives the flavor butter a wonderful
citrus zing
three cloves of garlic
turkey's a very delicate dainty meat and
that's why i want the garlic pureed so
it sort of disintegrates
and flavors a turkey
gently without becoming too overpowering
then add a generous handful of chopped
parsley
wow that smells incredibly light give
that a good mix
turkey's a very very very lean bird and
it dries out
so it's so important
to make sure that we help it to cook
perfectly
butter done now prepare the turkey we'll
season the bird
inside the
cavity
salt and pepper
next half two onions and pop them in
as they roast they steam inside the bird
giving a lovely sweetness
put in the lemon and a couple of bay
leaves for their bitter bittersweet
spicy flavour
[Music]
we're sort of lining the inside of the
turkey with these fantastic
sort of flavours you can see the bird is
upright and it's looking sort of like
it's standing to attention now it's time
to add the flavoured butter just very
very carefully
open up the skin
go through
over the back of the breast
and keep the skin intact
the idea is to gently loosen the skin
with your fingers so the butter can be
stuck underneath it
now once you've loosened all the skin
off the top of the thighs turn the bird
around
and just go through here again hand up
and just release
a little bit but don't completely break
it because i don't want all that butter
to run out
right
from there
now take your butter
put it into a bowl
that smells amazing
lemony
citrusy and just sort of flatten it
and stick that in there
underneath
one side now once you've got it in there
pull back the skin and just
use that
to sort of slide all the way down
what we want to do now is line the top
of the breast with all that butter there
that butter is going to keep the turkey
breast really seriously moist
turn the bird round
and finish covering the breasts with the
butter
turkeys originally came from north
america and they're best young and plump
my favorite breed for christmas is
either north of black or norfolk bronze
both of which have a wonderful gamey
taste take the rest of the butter and
carefully massage over the breasts legs
and wings
you can do all this the night before and
simply cover the turkey with tinfoil and
keep it in the fridge ready to be cooked
on christmas day
into the tray
a little touch
of olive oil now olive oil on top again
that protects it gets that skin really
nice and crispy and it stops the butter
from burning
now in the oven at 220 for 10 minutes to
get really nice and brown
quickly
in she goes
beautiful
[Music]
that smells fantastic
after 10 minutes take the turkey out of
the oven and baste then cover the
breasts with smoked streaky bacon
what i want to do
is add a little bit more flavor i'm
already starting to think
about my gravy
so the bacon protects it stops it from
drying out
but it's going to start
to really give
my gravy a wonderful base
turn down the oven to 180 degrees
this five kilogram bird will feed eight
people comfortably it needs roasting for
two and a half hours or half an hour per
kilo basting every so often
[Music]
back in
and now
she's on the way look at that beautiful
it's as pretty as the christmas tree
right
that smells
fantastic
wow
look at that
beautiful
that
is 90 of your work done there
to test the turkey is cooked stick a
knife into the bottom of the thigh and
if the juices run clear it's done the
secret now is to let the turkey rest
uncovered for two and a half hours as
the meat relaxes it reabsorbs its juices
making it succulent and tender plus
it'll be easier to carve
it might seem like a long time to let it
rest but remember the turkey doesn't
need to be piping hot because i'm
serving it with hot gravy
that
looks like a million dollars
let that rest
because the flavor will be 10 times more
exciting once it's rested
the key to pulling all the different
elements of your christmas dinner
together on the plate is the gravy my
recipe for turkey gravy made with cider
and walnuts has a wonderful aptly nutty
flavor which beautifully complements the
turkey meat and fruity pork stuffing
as that turkey's resting
i want to make the most amazing gravy
when i say amazing i really do mean
amazing
drain the excess fat from the roasting
tray and put it back on the heat
then remove the bacon from the top of
the turkey
and the roasted onions from the cavity
look at them
my god they smell amazing
finally take out the roasted lemon
first of all cut up the bacon
lovely
bacon into the tray
you know how crispy that is
that's the start
of our gravy
the onion look at it beautiful
doesn't get any better than that chop
that up
onion and bacon in
that
smells
incredible
when i first got the chance to cook
christmas lunch for the chefs in paris
they taught me one crucial thing
i was only 21 at the time
and they made me rest the turkey for as
long as i cooked it
so i cooked it for three hours and i
rested it for three hours
what a difference
incredible next chop up the roasted
lemon and add to the tray
put in a couple of sprigs of rosemary to
give it a lovely aromatic punch and fry
then add three chopped tomatoes which
helps to thicken the gravy and give it a
lovely fresh taste
[Music]
now it's time to really get the turkey
flavor into the gravy snap off
the wing
take off all your little trimmings all
these little bits here
add that into your crafty
these are the bits we never use
everyone throws them away
off
there that little baby there
take him off
i want that
bang flavor delicious try that off
it smells incredible
next pour in the dry cider this adds a
lovely subtle apple flavor that really
lifts the taste of the turkey meat
as the cider starts to reduce pour in
the delicious resting juices from the
roasted turkey
wow there you go
the most amazing flavour
[Music]
when the liquid has reduced by half
crush the vegetables and the turkey
pieces with a masher to extract the
maximum amount of flavor
and basically what's happening now is
that we're giving the gravy a little bit
of body pour in the chicken stock and
reduce again
in
now a little taste
wow i mean just close your eyes and wow
it oozes flavor and turkey now sieve it
use the back of the ladle to push it
through the sieve extracting every last
drop of flavour
pop in a sprig of rosemary and leave to
infuse ready for the finishing touch
[Music]
simply add crushed walnuts to the bottom
of the gravy boat and ladle in the hot
gravy
here's the turkey
right
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
you